[Music]
welcome back so I'm really excited today
to walk you through compressed sensing
which is a way of taking a high
dimensional signal like an image or an
audio signal and reconstructing that
signal even if you have massively down
sampled measurements so even if you only
had like 5% of the pixels in an image
could we reconstruct what was under that
image using kind of this this new
compressed sensing so really cool math
this is all relatively recent and this
is based on advances in sparse
optimization okay before starting I want
to point out that this all follows
chapter three of our new book
data-driven science and engineering so
you can go to the book website data book
UW comm slash data book dot PDF to
download a copy of this and all of our
code in MATLAB and in Python are on this
book website and on github ok
and again if you like this please
subscribe please like please comment I'm
gonna walk you through this compressed
sensing example today this is gonna be
really cool all right so the idea here
is we've already seen this before this
whole compression paradigm that I have
some really really high dimensional
signal X and again this might be
reshaped into a tall million pixel
vector okay and we know that when we
Fourier transform this image I can get
away with throwing away most of those
Fourier coefficients maybe I only keep
5% or 1% and when I inverse Fourier
transform that sparse signal s I recover
a pretty faithful representation of the
original image the original signal X
okay so here X is the image sy is this
Fourier transform and s is my sparse
signal after I've threshold it or
truncated most of the values okay now
this is standard compression this is
like on your smartphone and you know in
your computer every every computer worth
its salt has this you know Fourier
transform built in and you can do this
compression alright but this begs the
question and this is a relatively recent
advance in the last 15 or so years is
begging the question what if you
actually only had
a very few measurements of your systems
so remember we're starting with a
million pixels this kind of megapixel
image here and what we're going to do
the first step we're gonna we're gonna
do when we take this megapixel image is
we're gonna Fourier transform and throw
most of it away we're going to throw a
95 or 99% of this information away why
did I collect all of that information in
the first place so that's the whole idea
of compressed sensing is what if I start
with a massively down sampled or sub
sampled version of the image dye only
sample a small fraction of the pixels
can you from those those measurements
can you infer what the nonzero
coefficients are what this sparse vector
s had to be to be consistent with those
measurements and then from that sparse
vector s you can again inverse Fourier
transform and reconstruct the full image
X ok so that's the idea here
and I'm gonna write this down in math
we're going to assume that we have Y
which is some measurement of X okay and
I can write that as C times sy times s
and sometimes we call this matrix big
theta but the idea here is that Y is our
measurement and it you know ideally
we're gonna measure many many fewer
entries than we measured in X so if X
was a million entries maybe Y is only a
hundred thousand measurements or 10
percent of the original image okay and
you're not gonna be able to get a wave
with this for free I mean there's no
free lunch so if I am going to keep one
percent of my Fourier coefficients I of
course have to measure more than one
percent of my pixels you know probably
more like five or ten percent if I'm
gonna keep 10% of my Fourier
coefficients I might need to measure you
know thirty or forty percent of these
pixels so you know there are rules for
how this works sometimes it works
sometimes it doesn't
another one these measurements have to
be somehow random with respect to this
for a basis we'll talk about that later
if I only measure like the upper left
corner of this picture there's really
not enough information to tell what's
happening everywhere else in the image
so these kind of have to be distributed
in
random wave and I'm gonna make all of
these statements formal later on and in
future videos kind of one of the
mathematical conditions on the
measurements why that will allow us to
solve for this sparse vector s but
that's what we're trying to do okay so
the big point here is that we are going
to measure why we're gonna try to solve
for this sparse vector a so I'm just
literally going to circle that this is
what we're solving for and we're solving
for this sparse vector s that is
consistent with these measurements why
so that this equation holds we're going
to find that sparse s so that this
measurement equation holds and then once
we have s since we know that this was
sparse in Fourier we just inverse
Fourier transform and we recover our
full image that's compressed sensing
that's the whole picture okay and so
what I'm going to talk about is kind of
what are the mathematical conditions for
when you can solve this inverse problem
we're gonna talk about how it looks kind
of in terms of matrix systems of
equations and we're gonna walk through
all of those details but this is the
basic idea of compressed sensing is
instead of measuring the full image
we're gonna measure a dramatic subsample
of the image this C matrix is basically
this pixel mask here that's only
selecting you know some sub sample of
these pixels at random into this
measurement Y we're gonna use that Y to
infer our nonzero Fourier coefficients
in s and once we have that we basically
have the whole image because s and X are
almost equivalent representations of our
image I just have two Fourier transform
to go back and forth okay so in the next
video I'm going to show you kind of how
you would solve this what s so I'll give
you kind of a teaser this has infinitely
many solutions to this system of
equations okay there are s is a really
really tall vector million entries for a
megapixel image and Y is a small vector
so there are infinitely many S's that
solve this system of equations we're
gonna use a particular sparsity
promoting norm called the one noir
to find the particular s that
corresponds to this natural compressed
image all right that's all coming up
really excited to walk you through your
compressed sensing thank you